hallo und herzlich willkommen zur heute
show schön dass sie eingeschaltet haben
andererseits außer fernsehen kann man
gerade eh nix mehr machen wenn wir
ehrlich sind deutschland macht dicht
geht ja nicht anders geht ja nicht
anders soziale distanz ist das gebot der
stunde abstand zu menschen also genau
das was ostwestfalen wie ich schon immer
instinktiv richtig gemacht haben wir
erleben gerade eine völlig neue und
leider sehr bedrohliche situation da
gibt es keine einfachen antworten mehr
angela merkel hat sich vorgestern in
einer historischen tv ansprache direkt
an die bevölkerung gewandt und ich finde
es jetzt mal ohne ironie großartig dass
sie dabei anders klingt als ihre
europäischen kollegen die sind nämlich
alle längst im jahr feldherrn modus die
masse befinden uns im krieg mit einem
feind der unsichtbar ist wir werden uns
nie ergeben und wir werden sie neben uns
im krieg schon jetzt gibt es viele
kreative form die dem virus und seinen
sozialen folgen trotzen
schon jetzt gibt es enkel die ihren
großeltern einen podcast aufnehmen süß
ist oft nur ein ganz kurzer podcast oma
ich darf sie nicht besuchen über weiß
mir das oster geld einfach schön
entgegen manchen erwartungen hat die
kanzlerin noch keine bundesweite
ausgangssperre angeordnet
logisch grundrechte schafft man nur ab
wenn es gar nicht mehr anders geht und
es hat ja auch so schon fast alles zu
also bis auf das allernotwendigste
supermärkte apotheken friseure friseurin
anordnen läden zu keiner mehr zum
friseur
denn das hier ist nun fünfter geführt
super gefährlich super gefährlich was
ich hier mache unverantwortlich
natürlich müssen friseure auf bleiben
immer wie sehen wir sonst alle aus in
zwei drei wochen meiner ansicht nach
müssten sogar die waxing studios offen
bleiben egal
deutschland macht den charaktertest den
charaktertest während die einen für
ältere mitbürger einkaufen gehen feiern
andere immer noch corona partys corona
parties trotz der horror bilder aus
italien und spanien
ehrlich wie ignorant und asozial kann
man bitte seien hier mein lieblings
virologe erklärt nochmals für die doofen
in der letzten reihe
da gibt es dinge die kann man
leichtfüßig entscheiden wie zb spaß
veranstaltungen man muss nicht immer
spaß haben wenn es wirklich nur spaß ist
so schluss mit spaß der nur spaß macht
gut wenn das so ist das war die heute
show jetzt kommt aspekte nein ist
quatsch er hat ja recht
drosten hat recht bis es einen impfstoff
gibt müssen wir halt alle viel mehr zu
hause bleiben mir gefällt es da auch
nicht aber hilft ja nichts warum drängen
sich immer noch deutsche auf
wochenmärkten warum während sich
pflegepersonal und ärzte von morgens bis
abends reinhängen und wir sind ja nicht
die einzigen berufsgruppen die derzeit
alles geben
feiern wir bitte zum beispiel die frau
die sich jeden verdammten tag bei aldi
lidl oder rewe von hamsterkäufen an
husten lassen muss nennen wir sie mal
super kassier kommen wer fährt als
letzter durch die leere stadt und
liefert uns hässliche t shirts wie wir
am nächsten tag wieder retour schicken
kein geringerer als lieferbar und
natürlich der forstarbeiter der all die
bäume fällt aus denen dann unser
klopapier gemacht wird batman nur er
hält den laden hier anpacken helden
aber selbst diese superhelden retten uns
wohl nicht vor der großen rezession nach
allem was wir heute wissen
da kommt eine rezession und war das
wieder bitte an der frankfurter börse
diese woche die groko im krisenmodus
zumindest bis jetzt erstaunlich schnell
und effizient stemmt sich dagegen
wirklich mit tonnen von geld man könnte
auch sagen olaf scholz packt die kanone
aus ich weiß nicht ob man das hier sagen
haben
die bazooka mit der wir das notwendige
jetzt tun und was wir denn noch an
kleinwaffen brauchen das gucken wir
später olaf scholz bekannt aus dem film
scholz o2 die ganz große bazooka
die brauchen wir aber auch manche
branchen stehen jetzt schon vor dem aus
unsere autokonzerne haben die produktion
eingestellt und 5 millionen solo
selbständige müssen ja weiter miete
zahlen deswegen sollte die hilfe schnell
und unbürokratisch kommen gern auch
zinslos und viele deutsche die im home
office arbeiten märkten spätestens jetzt
dass wir mit der digitalisierung auch
immer noch hinterherhinken ich gehe
davon aus dass wir auch durch diese
krise einen schub bekommen werden und
dass die digitalisierung in deutschland
vorankommen unbedingt notieren vor der
nächsten pandemie an digitalisierung
arbeiten
da hätte man zwar auch ohne corona drauf
kommen können aber was soll's wir müssen
das beste draus machen wirklich wir
müssen das beste draus machen
gerade jetzt wo die schulen leer sind
und alle kinder zuhause abhängen aber
hier genau für sowas haben wir ja vor
einem jahr den tollen digital pakt
geschlossen wissen sie noch 5 milliarden
spendiert der bund für die
digitalisierung unserer schule abgerufen
wurden davon bis jetzt sekunde 40
millionen das ist schade
kommt dann eben kein digitaler
unterricht müssen halt mama und papa an
unter diesen umständen sind selbst die
kinder über das unverhoffte schulfrei
nicht wirklich glücklich ich finde es
eigentlich ein bisschen größer weil die
lehrer uns das erklären versteht es
manchmal sehr schnell satt machen wieder
weggeben
unverschämtheit immer die mama wäre
jetzt auch lieber beim pilates fräulein
ich glaube vielen eltern dämmert beim
sogenannten homeschooling so langsam die
schlimme erkenntnis lehrer ist wohl doch
ein regelrechter beruf hallo eltern wir
kennen uns ja vom elternabend da erzählt
er doch immer wie wir unseren job zu
machen haben damit aus euren verzogenem
brazen nobelpreisträger werden jetzt
könnt ihr uns ja mal zeigen wie viel
besser ihr selber unterrichten könnt und
dann merkt ihr sehr schnell dass euer
leon tiberius gar nicht hochbegabt ist
sondern einfach nur eine unglaubliche
nervensäge und dieser ramani die ist
auch nicht zu klug für die vierte klasse
im gegenteil wir geben euch maximal noch
eine woche dann dreht ihr komplett durch
schöne grüße euer lehrer verband
[Musik]
spätestens wenn man seine eigenen kinder
unterrichten muss merkt man home office
hat auch nachteile
nicht wenige mal ganz abgesehen von den
vielen branchen die regelrecht leiden
unter home office
[Musik]
home office ich bin zuhause home office
home office heißt das gebot der stunde
auch dieses studio hier wurde übrigens
im westflügel meiner privaten
gästetoilette aufgebaut aber das nur am
rande
satire und kabarett im home-office wie
geht das wir schalten wir live ins
wohnzimmer von birte schneider würde wie
geht es ihnen so nach einer woche arbeit
zu hause sie sehen etwas lese aus als
sonst wenn ich mir die private bemerkung
erlauben darf
ja und für wen soll ich mich zu hause
dann groß auf donnern für mein mann oder
wischmopp stellt keine ahnung sucht halt
man in der zeit wohl jeden scheiß
erkläre kein haus selber nach ein
vollidiot er wirklich sag ihnen im
herbst haben wir in deutschland die
höchste scheidungsrate aller zeiten
mit anderen worten sie sind home office
technisch noch in der findungsphase da
man wohl sagen man die schweine zwingen
mich den ganzen tag mit meinem kind zu
verbringen
man kriegt doch keine kinder um die
ständig zu sehen und zu hören ja von mir
aus kopf den rest auch noch eine
unangenehme stimmen das kind ist mir
früher nie aufgefallen
home office wo man wissen sie was das
einzige was ich gut finde wenn ich bei
einer skype konferenz kein bock mehr
habe tue ich einfach so als games netz
aussetzer kann kollegen verarschen mein
letztes kleines glück wird sich dann
schon mal die spülmaschine aus ja du
toll
mach das und sagt mir bitte unbedingt
immer was als nächstes muss es
interessiert mich total
ganz ehrlich ich weiß nicht wie lange
ich das noch durchhalten ich darf das
kind nicht zu oma und opa bringen
ich darf meinen mann nicht zu oma und
opa bringen der spielplatz ist
geschlossen und betreut werden nur noch
kinder von wichtigen leuten ein argument
gegen schulschließungen war zuletzt
immer wieder da
viele menschen den sogenannten
systemkritischen berufen ausfallen
könnten weil sie sich um ihre kinder
kümmern müssten auch nur noch kinder von
menschen in systemkritischen berufen
werden betreut
hallo ich bin kabarettistin ich
kritisiere unser system seit jahren
systemkritisch als ich geht gar nicht
das habe ich auch versucht der blöden
kate akku zu erklären
ja es ist alles nicht leicht da müssen
wir jetzt halt mal improvisieren
die deutschen sind doch gar nicht
gemacht fürs improvisieren herr welke
haben sie das gelesen bei den franzosen
sind jetzt wein und kondome ausverkauft
bei uns klopapier mehr muss man über
dieses land echt nicht wissen wir im
moment unseren klopapier fetisch den hat
aber neulich eine psychologin bei rtl
wunderbar erklärt
ja das hat offensichtlich etwas damit zu
tun dass wenn wir einen toilettengang
machen wir ihn auf die toilette gehen
dass wir uns verletzlich findet im
prinzip ist das toilettenpapier
stellvertretend für unser jetzt absolut
vorrang vorrangiges gefühl nach
sicherheit nach schutz nach halt und
nach orientierung
guck mal ich wünsche mir damit immer den
arsch ab aber jeder mensch ist halt
anders bitte ich will wieder ins büro
wollen sie mich hier raus bitte an einer
schlankeren peter schneider meine damen
und herren
[Musik]
wirte schneider ja die korona krise
trifft tatsächlich alle möglichen berufe
darunter auch bühnenkünstler die nicht
mehr auftreten dürfen
in diesem sinne begrüße ich jetzt den
frischgebackenen arbeitslosen olaf
schubert oder schön dass du da bist
kannst du noch ganz kleine stück weiter
abrücken geht das vielen dank
olaf du hast ja tatsächlich fünf kinder
von unterschiedlichsten frauen wäre geht
ihr das denn mit der betreuung
wir müssen uns helfen ganz klar also die
frauen tragen hier immer noch die
hauptlast in der betreuung und ich weiß
es auch aus meinem sozialen umfeld also
die mutter meiner kinder sind alle
alleinerziehend und da habe ich gesagt
ich bin solidarisch ich nehme jetzt auch
mal so ein kind und das ist jetzt
natürlich spannend wenn man es den
ganzen tag hat dann eben auch den
unterrichtsstoff nachzuvollziehen und
ich bin zum beispiel gut in mathe aber
was ich nie so richtig verstanden habe
war ja addition so unter weil eben jetzt
das tolle mit meinem sohn
er hat mir erklärt wie das funktioniert
und zwar wird dass da alles
zusammengerechnet also es wird immer
mehr also dass jemand plus sie hat es ja
ist gleiches kann perfekt also lernen
muss keine einbahnstraße sein
und wenn man eben zeit hat und mit
seinen kindern mal richtig kommuniziert
dann erfährt man eben auch was das ist
das tolle ich habe dann mit meiner
kleinen tochter so habe ich so gefragt
mensch wie ist es so in der kita und da
fing sie an zu erzählen und sagte ja sie
geht gar nicht mehr in die kita sondern
sie studiert biologie vierte semester
und hat selber kinder also und das ist
auch für mich dann eine völlig neue sich
dann verstehe ich auch klar vor zwei
monaten warum die sich so komisch
verhalten hat als ich mit puppen spielen
wollte also das ist eine tolle erfahrung
momentan findest du die massnahmen und
empfehlungen im kampf gegen korona
ausreichend so weit
ja ich denke es gibt maßnahmen die
wirklich positiv sind zb habe ich gehört
in
hamburg wurden mehrere obdachlose in
häusliche quarantäne geschickt und das
ist ja schon mal das ist ja fast ein
sozialer aufstieg
die schulschließung da bin na ja also
die schulschließungen kommen für mich zu
spät
also für mich exakt 40 jahre und härter
sind natürlich die kita-schließungen ich
habe das ein tag mit gemacht am zweiten
tag haben dass kindern trotzdem
abgegeben abgegeben zurückgelassen ich
meine ich hatte ja keine andere chance
ich muss mich dann auch wieder hinlegen
und dramatisch ist natürlich dass er
nicht nur institutionen geschlossen
werden sondern im endeffekt ganze länder
sehen wir italien frankreich und das
länder geschlossen werden das ist
natürlich für die menschen dort
furchtbar aber dass mein länder schließt
ich sag mal so es ist ja auch eine
chance
also wer schon mal in finnland war das
hatte ich schon vor 80 jahren dicht
gemacht also ich finde das sollte so
bleiben finnland kann man wirklich den
elchen zurückgeben oder schubert vielen
dank
ja und dann läuft gerade noch eine
gigantische rückholaktion über 100.000
deutsche touristen werden nach hause
geholt
denn aktuell müssen sie gilt eine
weltweite reisewarnung
das heißt uns wird explizit abgeraten
von reisen zum planeten erde
was schade ist denn der hat mein job
etwa 400 sterne und jetzt die pointe
während diese hunderttausend mitbürger
mit steuergeld und großem aufwand
zurückgeholt werden sind andere noch
diese woche in den urlaub geflogen mit
überzeugenden argumenten dadurch dass
die auch noch hinfliegen denke ich sind
ist die luft gesellschaft auch noch in
der verantwortung uns auch wieder das
irgendwann zurück zu bringen
vielleicht nicht zum geplanten
abflugdatum aber vielleicht zwei drei
tage später das risiko bleibt immer ein
bisschen da aber was ist ohne risiko da
eben
du kannst auch zu hause bleiben und dann
man spargel stechen von der leiter
fallen ja wir müssen unseren spargel
dieses jahr selber stechen hat es
gelesen die polen kommen nicht mehr und
in der eu gibt es wieder grenzkontrollen
grenzkontrollen schenk war gestern auch
an unseren grenzen wird kontrolliert
klar diese maßnahme hätte deutlich mehr
sinn gemacht als wir noch eine handvoll
infizierte hatten
jetzt ist es wohl eher symbolpolitik und
die frage ist ob man das alles nach
corona wieder zurückgedreht kriegt
glauben sie dass wir überhaupt wieder
zurückkommen zum das freien schenken
das hoffe ich ja ich auch übrigens hätte
die kanzlerin auch antworten können ja
klar was denn sonst hätte ich irgendwie
beruhigend gefunden vielleicht stirbt
gerade ganz nebenbei die europäische
idee und kein jux kein eu-land hat vor
den grenzkontrollen auch nur in brüssel
angerufen
es ist so bitter für ursula von der
leyen so bitter keiner meldet sich auch
noch vorher jetzt in der größten stadt
europas entpuppt sie sich doch eher als
machtloser grüßaugust klar in berlin da
kann sie natürlich zur not immer anruft
[Musik]
hallo angela jedes de ski ihr habt ja
jetzt die grenze zu gemacht habe ich in
der zeitung gelesen so was für europa
jetzt wahnsinnig wichtig wäre
wir müssten gemeinsam ja bei der
autorität frage ich mich wie sie sieben
kinder überlebt hat arme und plötzlich
wieder lkw staus mitten in europa weil
jedes land sein eigenes ding durchzieht
österreichs kanzler sebastian kurz zum
beispiel hier
da fällt mir ein wer betreut den
eigentlich jetzt wo die kitas zu sind
andere geschichte der hier gilt als
knallharter krisenmanager hat aber
erstmal überhaupt nicht mitgekriegt dass
ich in seinem skiparadies ich will ein
fetter infektionsherd gebildet hat da
hätte man das viel früher mit kriegen
müssen vor allem als ein barkeeper
positiv getestet wird
trotzdem erklären die behörden am 8 märz
eine übertragung des corona virus auf
gäste der bar ist aus medizinischer
sicht eher unwahrscheinlich eher
unwahrscheinlich sehr unwahrscheinlich
zu der einschätzung kommen aber auch
erst nach dem siebten gin tonic
inzwischen sind über 1000 europäische
corona fälle auf ich will zurück zu
führen
da sind jetzt aber mal konsequenzen
fällig
après ski nur ein harmloser spaß für
wintersportfans von wegen
après ski das steht für alkoholismus
ungewollte schwangerschaften und andreas
gabalier widerlich dauer geile
bustouristen auf engstem raum schäumende
körperflüssigkeiten plus die
virenschleuder nummer eins der german
knödel
deswegen fordert die heute-show apres
ski verbieten jetzt auch nach corona
[Musik]
absolut absolut verbieten liegt im trend
die großen länder der welt müssen sich
im kampf gegen korona endlich
koordinieren zusammentun
aber wie denn mit donald trump im weißen
haus der präsident der usa müsste
vorbild sein schüttelt aber weiter
öffentlich fast jedem die hand
er gibt jedem die hand und nachdem er
wochenlang die pandemie geleugnet und
klein geredet hat sagt er jetzt ohne rot
zu werden das ist endometriose pandemic
long before he is called a tramp ist man
eigentlich nur noch mühe es macht nicht
mal mehr spaß sich witze auszudenken an
der peinlichkeit front kann da überhaupt
nur noch ein mensch mit halten
thomas bach der deutsche präsident des
olympischen komitees herzlich willkommen
zum sport
[Musik]
fußball ist abgesagt formel 1 bleibt in
der garage basketball eishockey sogar
die handball liga ist abgesagt
und ich persönlich habe keine ahnung was
handball überhaupt ist aber macht
bestimmt spaß nur olympia soll unbedingt
stattfinden meint thomas bach auf der
twitter-seite des organisationskomitees
für tokio 2020 werden diese woche soll
ich witzig gemeinten videos der
maskottchen gepostet wird sich hier das
ist übrigens das neue maskottchen für
tokio 2020 das heißt kolonie das ioc die
einzige organisation bei der sogar die
fifa sagt alter die sind mir echt zu
korrupt hält ernsthaft an den spielen
von tokio fest hier thomas bach gerade
bei der üblichen fackel entzündungen in
griechenland wie olympic games audio
event that brings the end the world to
cover the japanese people will welcome
center world open arms ja super idee
alle in den arm nehmen gerade heutzutage
11.000 sportler aus 200 ländern lassen
sich anstecken vom olympischen geist
thomas bach krieg jetzt schon gold in
der disziplin ignoranz und komplette
realitätsverweigerung hochverdient
andererseits könnte man auch
argumentieren warum nicht olympische
boxen zum beispiel ist völlig okay wenn
man beim kampf mindestens zwei meter
abstand hält auch gewichtheben geht man
darf halt nur das gewicht nicht anfassen
und was spricht gegen schwimmen wenn man
nach jedem durchgang einfach das wasser
raus lässt ja das wird super das wird
super einfach mal positiv denken
lasst uns hoffen dass das olympische
feuer ein symbol des friedens und der
solidarität das virus auslöscht ja
problem gelöst pandemie zu ende einfach
alles abfackeln so viel vom sport
[Musik]
ja wirklich eine völlig neue welt in der
wir plötzlich leben nur eins bleibt wie
immer nicht so schlimm das ist das
internet nicht noch ein bisschen
schlimmer machen könnte herzlich
willkommen zu zdf spezial auch das noch
deutschland hat ganz schwer internet
unser heute-show betriebsarzt dr holger
stockhaus hat einen schlimmen verdacht
deutschland leidet unter internet leider
ja herr welke so langsam unser deutsches
netz ist es ist leider immer noch gut
genug um jeden tag neue corona
falschmeldungen und
verschwörungstheorien in die welt zu
blasen gehen sie mal nur eine sekunde
online sofort stattet ihn irgendein
zugekaufter youtuber sowas hier entgegen
das war es in den medien gesagt wird
stimmt nicht mit dem überein was gemacht
wird
diesen satz muss man kurz sacken lassen
dann wird einem erst klar wie epo war
blöd ist und leider ist das internet ein
erwiesener multiplikator von blödheit
deswegen sage ich wir müssen versuchen
die exponentiell ansteigenden
verbindungs kurve der bevölkerung zu
verflachen
da reicht es eben nicht die geschäfte zu
machen wir müssen fürchte ich auch das
internet zu machen
mindestens bis nach ostern bilden sie
sich ihre eigene meinung ob das corona
virus rein zufällig auftrat oder ob es
als eine militärische bio waffe gezielt
eingesetzt wurde kann man überhaupt der
regierung glauben da steckt ein plan
dahinter freunde
die wollen uns einschränken die wollen
uns kontrollieren das ist der erste
schritt besser ist nachgewiesen dass
corona während sich auch kupfer nicht
halten können jetzt können wir so klären
es ist offensichtlich was hier gerade
passiert und es schwimmen mir viel zu
viele menschen auf dem zug oder auf dem
strom mit psyche habe ich nichts
unterzujubeln
außer diese informationen und mein buch
finden sie die in dieser sendung
gezeigten fakten interessant nein
überhaupt nicht
liebe zuschauer wenn sie auch einen von
diesen idiotischen whatsapp kettenbriefe
bekommen zum thema corona bitte löschen
sie das sofort schmeißen sie danach das
handy weg und waschen sich dann
gründlich die hände versteht da so drin
schwachsinn halt zb wer zehn sekunden
die luft anhalten kann ohne zu husten
hat garantiert kein corona genau
und wer sich zehn sekunden lang mit
einem hammer auf den kopf haut wird
garantiert klüger andere empfehlen im
netz das gurgeln mit desinfektionsmittel
gut desinfektionsmittel trinken hilft
tatsächlich gegen bandwürmer aber eben
leider auch gegen menschen ja gut dass
sie das mal ansprechen der doktor zu
desinfektionsmittel hätte ich auch noch
mal eine frage die wende ich das zeug
korrekt amt na ja am besten so wie diese
amerikanischen eltern monday
der junge geht jetzt in die
blindenschule aber er hat kein grüner
verstehe also ihr ärztlicher rat meine
ärztlicher rat wäre wenn sie liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer unbedingt
ins internet müssen und ich rate
eigentlich grundsätzlich davon ab
dann informieren sie sich zum thema
corona bitte nur auf seriösen seiten wie
der vom robert-koch-institut oder bei
den bundesministerien entschuldigung des
opfers es gibt ja schon noch ein paar
andere interessante seiten im internet
ja klar absolut vielleicht wäre das hier
ja was für sie herr welke ist es für
dich überhaupt möglich in zeiten von
corona heute noch frauen anzusprechen
und zu verführen
herzlich willkommen mein name ist john
professioneller flirt trainer und dating
coach dating coach de sehr gut der
doktor stock aus vielen dank bis hierher
sekunde welcher bevor sie zurück ein
pult gehen muss ich sie noch ganz kurz
desinfizieren holger stockhaus
holger stockhaus vielen dank ja corona
corona corona bei den ganzen
sondersendungen freue ich persönlich
mich inzwischen schon wenn einfach mal
keine ahnung soko wismar läuft oder
nothdurft hafenkante irgendwas ohne
corona dietmar wischmeyer versucht uns
allen mal ein bisschen mut zu machen
kinder
was war das früher schön die welt vor
corona mit dietmar wischmeyer wie schön
war das doch vor corona als man noch
nicht jeden tag lesen und hören musste
was b promis so über pandemien denken so
kriegt zb sophia thomalla aus ihrer
geistigen quarantäne und postet das
einzig gute in dieser zeit keine termine
und leicht einen sitzen hashtag corona
beziehungsweise hashtag wer hat dich
dann gefragt wenn überhaupt fragt man
jetzt alte weiße medizinmänner man so zu
schützen das habe ich immer gemacht ich
habe mir fünf sechs mal am tag die hände
gewaschen sowieso nur um jetzt mache ich
morgens gehe ich ins bad und amtsgericht
noch mainz bad heino west sich plötzlich
zwei mal am tag das hilft zwar nicht
gegen kronau aber für hannelore es ist
doch schön wie sie noch worüber wir uns
vor corona aufgeregt haben vor genau
einem jahr waren das hier die topnews
die raupe nimmersatt feierte ihren
fünfzigsten und eine soulige brite
namens theresa may hat jeden tag
vorschläge gemacht zum sogenannten brics
it heute weiß keiner mehr wer die eine
oder was das andere war vor einem jahr
haben wir deutschen für ein süßes eisbär
mädchen im berliner tierpark 5300
namensvorschläge gemacht und
ausgerechnet der ist es geworden
hertha gut dass die kleine nicht lesen
kann
sonst würde sie sicher ihre frühstücks
aber halb verdaut zurück in den tümpel
feiern
apropos halb verdaut habe die finnen
waren vor allem laut umfragen die
glücklichsten menschen der welt großes
thema bei uns war da noch die angst vor
der illegal eingewanderten
südamerikanischen weißen bieber hatte
weil die löcher in unser schönes
deutschland bündelt
okay das ist nicht gerade germany's next
top lage aber heute wissen wir wie das
weiße pisten nackt aussieht
aber ich behaupte es gibt eine zeit nach
corona und dann werden wir uns auch
wieder über tiere und b-promis aufregen
denn wie hat die große virologin lady
gaga gerade getwittert ich habe mit gott
gesprochen sie hat gesagt wir werden
okay sein
da musst du einmal bei gott an und dann
geht nur seine frau dran
naja in diesem sinne verabschiede ich
mich mit dem deutschen corona gruß
allzeit guten stuhl und immer eine
handbreit wasser im bdm eine art
geigensolo war doch versprochen ihr
könnt ja in der zeit den kanal
abonnieren
[Musik]